Hi, I'm James.
Welcome to this course on Canvas 2D.
We're going to teach you how to use the canvas API using memes with my
co-instructor, Cameron.
Cameron.
>> Oh.
Hey, sorry.
Am I late?
My bad.
>> So much for coordinating what we're going to wear beforehand.
Let's fix that.
>> Huh.
Doge.
I like it.
>> So, what's with the box?
>> Well, you said we'd be painting with canvas, right?
So, I brought some acrylics, I brought some brushes, I brought a palette.
>> Hold, hold up.
I'm going to give you an A for
effort, but I actually was talking about the canvas API inside the browser.
So, we're going to do all our painting with JavaScript code.
>> Oh, oh, that kind of Canvas.
My bad.
Well, anyways, the Canvas is a powerful API which you can use to edit,
resize and otherwise change images, animations, and interactions.
>> Though we won't cover it any detail,
you can even use the Canvas to create games that run inside the browser.
Okay.
Let's get started.